[Music]
so what were we talking the cover of
science it was that it's actually very
interesting to to take a look at this
and see and see what the problems are
and whether or not this is really
working as a description of what this is
about
yes what were you saying Tom that well
I've always thought that that is a you
know a spectacular graphic and it has a
lot of positive aspects about it
conveying what we are thinking about
when we talk about bose-einstein
condensation but it also has the
possibility for some misconceptions hmm
I'm not sure whether we should start
with the misconceptions and I think we
just did
that's indicate as being the molecule of
the year and in a way that's a joke
because the Bose condensed state is
certainly not a molecule but there's a
misconception possible misconception
there because of previous molecule of
the year was C 60 which was a molecule
I'm sorry so this is a crystalline know
in C 60 there's a geometrical array and
if you look at this you see immediately
a geometrical array he said oh maybe in
the Bose condensed state there is
spatial order and that's a misconception
because there is no spatial order there
in the way that there is in C 60 right
well these are the difficulties for
people like me who are coming on this
pretty much for the first time and the
the grasping this notion of quantum
states as opposed to this states that
were somewhat more familiar with atomic
states if I could say it that way it's
extremely difficult for us to truly
grasp it and I don't even know if we're
able to without the mathematics that's
something that I would be interested in
your take on whether you can
doing that but the words are the things
for problem
it's the condensate idea that is strange
yes because it is a condensate but not
in the space that's a condensate of his
kind I would like to follow your
simplicity and say it's a condensate in
wavelength space which represents the
wave nature of the atoms that make
enough just as the position the ordinary
space represents the particle nature and
because this is a mixture of the two
we've got to have that point of view but
just be careful without tools because
condensating say wave vector space makes
you think is going into a given momentum
state a given wave vector and if you're
in a trap that's not true either because
here well your range is smaller that's
true here you are condensing into a
quantum mechanical State the ground
state yes and what people don't
understand is that in a quantum
mechanical state you there is not a
single position there is not a single
velocity but there's a distribution of
positions for example the 1s the
electron in a hydrogen atom in the
chemistry textbooks from high school you
see a cloud of position right and that
gets across to the student at least the
idea the position isn't certain in the
trap the same thing is true of the
velocities the velocities happy
distribution sort of a class one losses
but I would call them wavelengths but a
distribution of them yes can't spread of
wavelengths can we talk about that issue
is probably not a good word can we talk
about a wave can we start there do you
think that's a good place to start
do do you think we could uh I'd like to
come back to the cover because Wolfgang
was telling me about a very interesting
interpretation of that on the positive
side when you were talking to a group of
people they have an actual and discover
too many people and I think it conveyed
something to them it's sort of the
question how you address it whether use
you want to convey that this is like
crystallized structure but my take on it
is that these guys are all identical and
they could be anywhere
it's not that we mean the a localized is
just it's a group
people which is sort of smeared out over
this region and those people have lost
the identity they are faceless they
march in lockstep so for me this
represents how I describe Bo's
condensates as many mehta waves
oscillating in concert and this is sort
of what you associate many people
marching in lockstep that's what exactly
post colonization is about many atoms
marching in lockstep hey the key word is
loss of individuality which which i
think is it is not clear here oh I think
it is I mean the colors that all the
colors have now become the same I see
but I see individual I see individual
pieces that's the part that for me has
gotten in the way an army of soldiers
where everybody looks to see him there
is no individual okay well then that we
need the words then see that there's a
drawing in that in that slideshow that
has maybe four steps of change ending at
one point just having waves see let's
see this is it yes yes I think that is a
wonderful let me see I think if you talk
about that in relation to this this is a
little cleaner I think do you want to
just go through that perhaps it could be
helpful for us this is exactly the two
spaces and I was done what do you think
I mean I think what we are facing here
is the misconception between crystalline
structure and atoms being smeared out
and I've also seen that in the public
among journalists it became quite
popular to see the post condensate is a
state where many atoms merge into a
super atom I always felt that this was a
very dangerous phase
if by super Adam you mean that many
atoms are just in one state and are one
entity this is okay but many people
would associate with super Adam for the
term what you were referring to like a
super molecule something which is really
a different kind of entity but my take
is harder the post condensate should be
more described by meta meta waves
oscillating in concert and if you want
to go one step further in depicting it
it would be atoms marching in lockstep
but it is the same atom it's it's the
same atom we put in but those atoms now
march in lockstep it's not that the
atomic nature has changed it's not that
atoms have fused into a bigger entity
it's more this acquaintance coherence is
marching in lockstep which distinguishes
the porcelain state if the lockstep is
with their paces footprints yes yes and
what yet and and what gets them into
this lockstep that's just the way yeah
some kinds of things transition which
sometimes it's really a qualitative
difference between these two states of
matter and the interesting thing is that
there are many phase transitions in
nature the simplest one is the freezing
of water
another more esoteric one is the lining
up of all the magnetic moments to form a
magnetic bar of iron for example all
other phase transitions in nature every
single one of them is mediated by an
interaction between the particles and
interaction between the spins
interaction between the the water
molecules this one they're no interact
well they don't have to be interactions
this would take place even if there were
no interactions if these atoms could
just pass right through each other not
even a hard sphere radius now there is a
weak interaction but it turns out that
this transition does not depend on that
interaction
that's one of the reason that physicists
I think are so excited about this
transition
do you also why I could have been found
out before there was even in quantum
mechanics yeah it was found out by using
that simple it's just the statistical
mechanics which is two ways and this
this is where the problem is for
laypeople as myself to understand that
even in the notion of statistical
quantum mechanics is extremely difficult
for someone like me to to grasp we have
to completely we have to think
completely differently don't we where do
we even begin I guess I mean this is not
a fair question to just throw at you but
is there is there a place I mean even to
even repeat ourselves a little bit
perhaps we're where can we start where
can someone like myself start thinking
about a quantum mechanical state do I
have to do I have to erase something
from my head to begin is it about
erasing a discrete particle do we have
to stop thinking about things being
discrete or maybe it's a little more
sophisticated than that you have to stop
thinking about the possibility of
following a particle along a trajectory
so if there's one major difference that
I think of between a classical system
and a quantum mechanical system but
classically you can imagine following a
particle along a trajectory it has a
velocity it moves you can't do that in
quantum mechanics because if you do find
out if you determine that it's in one
place and going in a given direction
then you completely change the nature of
the system afterwards the particle does
have a distribution of positions and has
a distribution of momentum so if you
make a measurement you'll get a result
but you have to think about the system
in terms of possessing a distribution
both of positions and velocities say but
I think we have some
access to this reality if you think in
terms of waves I mean we malls in
waterways yes and this is what is
depicted here that I mean the picture we
have to break with is the picture in the
first panel namely that particles have
position and velocity right but if we
sort of add on that particles are not at
a given position and have a certain
velocity they are rather quaint to
mechanically smeared out the I often say
atoms are not hard billiard balls they
are fuzzy objects but this is just a way
to circle summary that they are it's not
that the atom itself is fuzzy we just
don't know where it is and so therefore
my knowledge where the atom is is fuzzy
so therefore without explaining exactly
what it means you would use the language
of quantum mechanics and the
mathematical description I just would
convey that atoms are kind of fuzzy
objects they had sort of smeared out and
this is what we call a wave packet in
our language I think the use of the word
wave is wonderful and indispensable
should really the basis of what you mean
by quantum is so an atom is a wave
period period it was also in the belief
is characterized by certain wavelengths
and the wavelength determines also what
is the extension of the wave packet so
my understanding is that atoms are kind
of fuzzy but when we extract energy from
the system and we classically slow the
atoms down
this means in the wave picture that the
waves the wavelength gets longer and
longer or the fuzziness of the atoms
increase and if we continue this cooling
the atoms get faster and fuzzier and
neighboring atoms start would touch each
other start overlap oh this is very nice
this is here then the atoms overlap and
then all those waves start to oscillate
in concern they just super nice a third
step
they deny Sara right right up one
problem with the wave pictures when when
someone thinks of a wave they think
about a very definite wavelength yes in
this particular case there is a
characteristic distance which one uses
instead it's called the thermal de
Broglie wavelength and it's sort of an
average wavelength that can also be
looked at as a characteristic length and
that's what I've tried to indicate in
this diagram the characteristic length
is sort of an average over all the
wavelengths associated with a quantum
mechanical particle but it does give you
a physical distance scale at high
temperatures that distance scale is
extremely small and it can be actually
smaller than the actual physical extent
of the the atom itself on the other hand
as you cool it down this extent grows
and really what it is is the region over
which the particle is felt statistically
not over not the range over which you
feel it's real force but the range over
which is presence is made known through
statistical mechanics so here the little
red dot would be the hard sphere radius
it's the region of force but now the de
Broglie wavelength is characteristic
length can become so large that the
particles are very far apart compared to
their characteristic size hard sphere
wise force ones but they are all
overlapping they are all feeling each
other's presence statistically that's
what I was trying to get across there
but you're right fellas that an
intermediate step would help also I
think it would help if there were a haze
over the over the hardware yes so that
there's a sense of the dimensionality in
fact one of the problem again coming as
a non-scientist
when I see drawings of electromagnetic
fields well you know it's and I'm awful
at this of course but yes let's get that
you would well I don't know if this is
even close to what whatever maybe you
could do better
yes or just some sort of things like
that is that it's not really but but
when you're describing electromagnetism
and fields it it seems as if when you
draw the line that's the place where
something exists and the empty space
between it indicates that nothing exists
and that's not quite exactly what it's
about is it but that's something that
you you all accept as protocol of some
sort is that this is just the same is if
you have a topological map the map a
certain contour lines but it doesn't
mean that there is no limit just
indicate with certain lines what is
characteristic for the distribution but
that that's coming with knowledge a you
know we're kind of talking about people
coming without any sort of knowledge and
probably that's not who we're talking to
in this conversation but there's a
somewhat of a counterintuitive feeling
when somebody's not used to working with
these kinds of things to understand that
there's a gradient of some or is that
the right word gradient yeah and then
back to trying to understand the Bose
condensate yeah I was trying to think of
it in terms of misconceptions and
there's another misconception I think
that keeps many people in the public
from understanding just parties that
we're doing because one of the things
that students seem to leave high school
with is the concept that absolute zero
is the place where all matter comes to
rest all motion stops but now we're
talking about a bose-einstein condensate
which is near or almost at Absolute Zero
yet we talk about motion we're talking
about Hanson fact of the matter is that
absolute 0 at Absolute Zero particles do
not come to rest the truth
is that an absolute zero you can no
longer extract any energy from the
system without destroying it and that's
that's quite different but take as an
example the electron moving around by
the nucleus of a hydrogen atom it's in
its ground state it's an absolute zero
yet if you make a measurement of the
velocity you'll get a result if you make
that measurement again and again and
again you get a distribution of results
because there's no one velocity
associated with but there's certainly a
kinetic energy it is in the best sense
of the word moving even though it's an
absolute zero so coming back to the bows
condensate
they they would think oh well why aren't
they all at rest also odd common sight
words such as yes slightly troubling one
because it implies a high density its
first maybe stick to I think Tom's SP
should maybe be a little bit further
level resident one thing is you can even
I think many people have heard about
Heisenberg's uncertainty relation so if
you just say take one of those pictures
and say look this is a condensate the
condensate is extended over certain
elite which you might call delta x and
then people know that there's and
Eisenberg's uncertainty relation which
says that if Delta X is the uncertainty
in position there's an Associated
uncertainty in momentum and if there's a
momentum uncertainty
it means the silver point motion there
is some 20 mechanical motion associated
with that system that's a nice way of
getting to it without doing any
mathematics yes concept of the
Heisenberg yes then allows you to
explain the motion velocity can only
feel sharp
zero when the object has infinite extent
if it has infinite position uncertainty
then momentum can be sharp and can be
silver but as long as we are talking
about finite size objects and this is
what the experimental Bose condensates
are about the millimeter/submillimeter
links with
there is a momentum uncertainty
associated and that means motion that
means zero point motion and that's
related to temperature no it's just ok
because I just well just just what we I
thought I remembered was that movement
it has is related to when atoms move
quickly the temperature is high is that
not right no that is true it's just that
they're two different contributions to
the motion of the atom one is the
contribution to having to do with
Heisenberg's uncertainty principle mhm
the other is the fact that if you're at
a high enough temperature that you can
start talking about the position if you
can use this image then there is a
thermal contribution to the motion as
well and there it is true that the
kinetic energy is directly rated related
at the temperature in fact in in both of
our experiments in the gas the portion
of the gas that has not condensed we
measure the temperature by measuring the
distribution of the losses of the
distribution momentum so we use that as
a but when they go into the condensate
as far as temperature is concerned it's
as though they were at zero temperature
and then the contribution to the
distribution I mean it's a subtle point
if I give its thickness if I give a
simple popular talk I usually say
temperature is just energy temperature
is a way how we measure energy and then
I immediately try to demystify that some
people into the notion that the absolute
zero can never be reached I mean this is
two and this is false and they're
sometimes compare it to
can you reach absolute zero pressure
that depends I mean if you suck out of
the chamber you suck out the air and
you're very good pumps you can reduce
the pressure to smaller and smaller
values but there are always a few atoms
and molecules named so
pressure is never rigorously zero but
it's clear the harder you suck the
harder you pump the closer you come to a
completely empty chamber chamber and
temperature means for our physical
systems that they're empty of energy we
have sucked out we have extracted all
the energy so there is no mystery about
zero it just means we remove the energy
from the system so therefore temperature
is just a measure of energy but now when
we talk about the zero-point energy and
more general forms of energy we have to
be a little bit careful because then
temperature is not associated to the
total energy but to the energy which can
still be extracted from the system and
it would also lead us to connect
temperature not to energy but to an
energy distribution you know if the
bullet moves it moves fast it has energy
but the bullet might be cold so the
emotional energy is something we would
disregard we are just looking for the
internal energy of the bullet when we
use the word temperature so one has to
be careful away you can go very far by
just setting temperature and energy
equivalent you can convey a lot of basic
concepts but you find your limits at
some point yes but if if what you're
thinking is how to reach a wider
audience then to talk about energy and
temperature together makes it more than
twice as hard because those are each
hard things and for people who haven't
thought it through
so it's a case where you make it harder
by making that comparison is that is
there a way that you would prefer to
draw a picture of temperature for
example to show what happens when things
get cooler there is one he drew it
very truncated to this particular
discussion yes
history shows the state's dinner box yes
and some no no another much more
technically okay okay do it was it on
the okay let's let's see this one oh
yeah okay that would be great yeah this
is a great thanks do you want to just
wait would you mind taking us through
this this just explains what happens
that she goes well maybe we could could
let me know what it looks could you
sketch it's good yeah okay but of course
this now evolves our concept of plan to
mechanical States each of those lines is
it went to mechanical State and we can
indicate how many atoms are in that
state by just drawing a few now the
y-axis there is energy so we know what's
going upwards okay yes so each one of
those states has a successively higher
energy we go up from the bottom of the
trap and as we cool down there is less
and less energy available and that means
the particles will eventually occupy
lower lying States the final state would
be and this is what the post condensate
is that almost all the particles are in
there always wins
okay so this is DP that's why the energy
distribution of wonder so there's one
difference uh-huh that is what you
described so far would make it seem as
though what you're doing is simply
reducing the temperature lower and lower
and lower and finally getting to
absolute zero yeah that's not what
happens here what happens is that an
amazing thing you lower the temperature
and lower the temperature and then
suddenly
at a given temperature a finite fraction
of the atoms start populating the lowest
ground state you still have a
distribution up here but the lowest
state develops extremely high population
for example you know there are millions
of these states even very close to the
place where the transition takes place
and each one of those states is occupied
by a few atoms one two maybe three when
the bose-einstein condensation takes
place the ground state instead of being
offered occupied button one two or three
ends up being occupied by one two or
three percent of the entire population
so you can end up with billions of atoms
in the ground state and then the next
day dog can have 796 with a number it is
it isn't a continuous distributions of
phase transition so it's continually
going to zero as I would if if these
were all these didn't have both
statistics all three just are our
conception of a classical atom yes they
would the lower the temperature the more
strongly peaked they would be but still
there would be a distribution and it
would be smooth with a bose-einstein
condensation you have a smooth
distribution in one singular point at
the lowest one of the reasons why this
is so lovely for more innocent people is
that the image itself very subtly says
it can be here and here but not in
between it gets you thinking about in a
very useful another thing which I like
about it especially is but a new space
is because you're just not even saying
very much about it
have to be sitting on a line next to
each other they could be a triangle this
has nothing to do with where they were
though saying that's why one often
speaks about the energy because the
energy is a property of one of these
states where as position and velocity or
momentum are not properties they can be
and there are only some possible
energies this looks so innocent but it
was indeed in the history of science
revolution for decades or for centuries
people thought particles are independent
I sort of described my system by
describing each particle and then in
1924 in Boozer we derived the Planck
radiation law he sort of treated
electromagnetic waves and photons in a
peculiar way it was sort of following
that kind of just putting particles or
photons into certain States and Einstein
generalized into atoms but what happens
in this innocent way is that we are not
regarding the particles as independent
anymore but the quantum states which are
indicated here with lines and this is
one of the most revolutionary steps from
classical physics to quantum physics by
focusing on States on disk reads 22
States and not on the particles anymore
which goes very strongly the problem of
identity would you've solved only in
quantum mechanics I was thinking this
brings us back to the cover again
because if a very large fraction of the
atoms are in the ground state then
they've lost their identity they're just
all in that one state and here you can
talk about them as being different
because they have different energy the
thousands millions of atoms that are in
the ground state they're all identical
and they're correlated in that if you
determine where one is then that tells
me that others may not be nearby
it's a correlated state they're not
independent but they have lost their
individual identities so the cover made
the attempt what we do here is lines
coated in color yeah the blue color is
the lowest line in this day yes but you
can't you can't tell that by looking
whereas you can tell this is some sort
reaching toward some sort of a limit and
you can also tell that there is a
distinct difference between what the
different lines represent and that's so
useful to the people who don't know much
because it's a case where an image tells
you more than you had to learn its
structures your thinking and that's
lovely then you could use the blue line
always to represent the ground state
material a lot of problems not even
saying so maybe you just pick that one
maybe say this is the lowest state I
still worry about the localization but
that's the nother problem but whether
this is the right picture I think it's
it's it's finally starting to seep in a
little bit for me and this is actually
quite exciting I the the the part that
is it's always difficult and it is to
try to connect it if necessary to what
we experience in our lives and we can't
with this situation the for whatever
reason people enjoy the metaphor
somewhat that is - it's easier to grasp
that's something if they can they can
connect it with some experience in their
lives
and I think in this situation it's
extremely difficult just or unless you
have any ideas about that but yes Damian
every kid is familiar with ELISA ok so
they know about the optical is a
phenomenon the optical is a phenomenon
is also a phenomenon related to
indistinguishability or photons into the
wave nature of light I think we can use
I often explain bose-einstein
condensation as something which is
similar to the optical laser mm-hmm if I
want to explain what is the difference
between the bose-einstein condensate and
an ordinary stale of atoms I see it's
the same difference between laser light
and the light bulb in laser light we
have all the photons marching in
lockstep we have all the photons
occupying the single same mode mode is
the same thing as a state the same state
of the electromagnetic field and we all
know how different how strikingly
different the properties of laser light
are as compared to ordinary light
directional propagation extreme
intensity can be focused to a pinpoint
and all those properties are now
repeated on the atomic level with the
bosons and condensate that's so the
bose-einstein condensate is for matter
what the laser is for light the only
difference was that originally the
bose-einstein condensates did not have a
direction associated with them or as one
thinks of a laser being there's a
direction but Wolfgang has solved that
Wolfgang has made actually a beam of
these coherent atoms so you have a
coherent state in a beam and the analogy
is now complete and direct but even
before that if you use an analogy
instead of States and our events we are
very familiar in physics that there are
states where light goes in one direction
or when the light is between two rivers
goes back and forth so it has lost its
directionality and we could even go so
far that the light is in a spherical
cavity so it has completely lost its
sense of direction but it is a wave with
boundary conditions so what was a
propagating wave and we know propagating
ocean waves now just becomes
a bathtub whether some waves are just
kind of oscillating back and forth
without any direction so once we accept
that waves and propagation is not
necessarily connected a wave is just
state is a mode we can make very close
connections do you do you feel like
going through the process and in a
minimal kind of way and actually what
what you began with and what you wound
up with is it is it possible to do that
it's somewhat skimming the surface in a
in a yes no I'm sorry the the forming
the condensate the laser be what you
just did in in kind of a series of steps
to somewhat be take us from it from a
get a beginning to an end in had told me
those much more about the beginning
survived I don't think you want
historical no no I think you want some
idea of how you can create from that
yeah and hydrogen and the alkalis all
starts differently that's a good
critical matter which I don't think is
is it is that no uh-huh but I think once
you get to a collection of rather cold
atoms and you can start to do
evaporative cooling then the two are
cooled in exactly the same way more
generally by seeing in principle to do
bose-einstein condensation is a very
simple experiment all you have to do is
you have to cool down we have to extract
energy from your system and if you have
an atomic system if less and less energy
it means that that the poi wavelengths
the meta wavelengths get longer and
longer the fuzziness of the atoms gets
more and more pronounced and feel cool
sufficiently far down then those wave
packets
and they form the condensate so when we
talk about our experiments and there is
a decade-long story it's just the story
how can you extract energy form an
atomic system they said more than a
decade because Einstein was what 1925 so
it's been a long time and the major
problem is that as you cool down any gas
it undergoes a phase transition but a
rather common phase transition it free
it condenses into a liquid and then if
you which is very dense okay and then if
you cool it further it forms a solid so
you no longer have a gas you no longer
have the opportunity of looking at this
even helium which resists condensation
into a liquid to the very lowest
temperature you have to go to about four
degrees Kelvin before we can liquefy it
even then it's a gas this system is very
strongly interacting and the the real
interactions between the particles
dominate the the subtle statistical
mechanical effect that you're looking at
here so the problem was to find a way of
keeping the atoms from doing this and in
Wolfgang's case with the the alkalis it
was to work with a gas which remained
well a vapor I guess is the right way of
putting it so tenuous that although left
for a long period of time it would
condense into a solid the three-body
collisions that were necessary to start
have forming little droplets just were
so rare that they never took place
hmm it turns out that two alkali atoms
can collide but there's no way that they
can stick together and conserve energy
and momentum it takes three and if you
bring three together then two of them
can stick together stay as a molecule
the third can take away the excess
energy and momentum and then those two
it's a molecule it freezes out on the
wall you've lost it but if as Wolfgang
and others
managed to do they kept the density so
low that there were two body collisions
yes you could exchange energy but the
three-body collisions were so rare that
it would take days longer than the to
form a solid and they could do the
experiments when what tom is alluding to
is we've discussed here very paradoxical
situation we've talked about extremely
low energy no temperature properties of
a gas and low temperature means on the
scale of the experiments microkelvin
millionths of a degree Kelvin or even
none okay so really cold but now we
should ask ourselves what substance in
nature is still gaseous is a gas at such
low temperatures and the answer is
simple none there is no matter as far as
we know which is gaseous at those low
temperatures but now we have this
remarkable predictions that a gas at
such low temperatures would show
wonderful novel Quenton properties so
this seemed to be a certain dilemma
you might formulate it that it's
impossible to do it but you say
something is impossible it's just a
challenge always just explained the way
how we could make it possible
namely if the gas is sufficiently dilute
it takes a long time for the gas that
many atoms find each other from droplets
form molecules form clusters so there is
a long period where the gas is still
gaseous although an infinite time the
atoms would find each other and form
higher aggregates so we can under call
the gas we can keep substance gaseous
although thermal equilibrium would
require it to freeze to a solid so that
turns out the 1/3 of the problem the
second third of the problem is that if
you have the atoms at a very low density
you still have to confine them somewhere
and if the atom hits a wall yeah then it
will stick to the wall it would add sorb
I
van der Waals interactions if nothing
else and you would lose it it would just
stick to the wall more and more atoms
would stick to the wall they would come
together they would form a solid walls
are out you can't have right so the
trick here was to form a magnetic trap
all of the atoms that we work with have
magnetic moments and we can trap them in
a magnetic potential a magnetic trap
which does not allow them to reach the
walls at all so that solves to kind of a
suspension but that is just it just kind
of stays there it just is right so we
have atoms floating in a vacuum chamber
because magnetic forces compensate defy
gravity not only gravity because you
don't only want to keep them from the
bottom of the trap you want to keep them
from the walls as well yes so it's a
three-dimensional trap yeah so that
takes care of the problem of keeping
them from combining into a solid then
the last third of the problem was how do
you cool it you have a gas it's isolated
from the walls how do you get it to a
very cold temperature and once you have
it in a trap then there's a simple
technique that you can use the trap has
walls for example
okay this is meant to indicate in a
one-dimensional way the trap you have
the minimum energy the energy rises as
you move away from the physical location
in the middle of a container but if you
go far enough in one direction you can
go over the edge of the trap that is you
can actually get out and go to another
location a location where you're no
longer magnetically trapped where you
can hit the wall the atoms that managed
to make it to this this high in energy
if they have enough energy to get over
the wall they then disappear from the
trap but when they do so they take away
an amount of energy you pulled about
hottest atoms in the trap so the atoms
that are escaping are the very hottest
atoms then the atoms that remain behind
they still collide with each other they
exchange their energy and they come to a
new equilibrium at a lower temperature
that trap is exactly parallel to the
Trump but they make for themselves and
they become a solid or fluid when you
heat the fluid the same thing happens
that's our escape the trapping effects
immediately so if we kept the trap
barrier at the same height we would
continually get rid of the hottest atoms
but the temperature would getting colder
and colder so the atoms would fall
deeper and deeper into the trap and
fewer would go out as a function of time
what we did was to slowly lower the
barrier in time now it turns out but we
can do that because the barrier is a
magnetic bear don't you just turn down
the magnetic field under the trap and
the atoms go out and it turns out it
doesn't that doesn't affect what's going
on in here not if you do it slowly
enough if you ramp down the magnetic
field at a rate which is slow compared
to the time that it takes atoms to
re-equilibrate it turns out that for
geometrical reasons there is a
relationship between the height of the
barrier and the temperature of the atoms
that are in the trap it's about a tenth
so the temperature for the corresponding
energy
is about one tenth of the energy or the
temperature that it takes the atoms to
escape so if we drop this by a factor of
two then the temperature drops by a
factor two how do I and we just keep
going and going it works beautiful how
wonderful well there was a problem the
problem was that in our trap we started
this with atomic hydrogen we could only
let the atoms out of one end of the trap
and we have a long narrow trap that was
just logistic it was going up that's
right when people think of long and
narrow they think of something like this
actually our aspect ratio was four four
hundred to one it was very strange and
this was only at one end so this was not
a very efficient way of allowing the
atoms to evaporate out what Wolfgang did
was to use a different technique he used
an RF magnetic field a a resonance
experiment to flip the spins
now if since we're trapping by trapping
the magnetic moment if you flip the
moment from being up to down the atom
instead of seeing a confining potential
see the repulsive potential and it gets
kicked out of the trap but now if you do
a resonance experiment if you put on a
frequency an RF frequency it only
resonates with atoms at a very special
magnetic field but that means since this
is a magnetic trap at a very special
position in the trap
so what Wolfgang did was to start his RF
frequency at a very high value which
resonated with energy atoms in the trap
at high energy kicked those out and then
lowered the frequency and successively
he moved downwards and here instead of
just letting the atoms out at one end of
the trap there's a killer surface all
the way around the trap everywhere a
two-dimensional surface all the way
around on which the atoms are being
kicked out much more efficiently
and that's the way that they got to
bose-einstein condensation in the
alcohol of course we weren't dumb and
you laughter we saw that they had
approved improved our techniques we use
their improved think they can finally we
were able to get there too so that's of
the three problems with getting the
bose-einstein condensation there's low
density to keep the atoms from
condensing into a real liquid or solid
there is the magnetic trapping keeping
them away from the walls and then
there's the evaporation or cooling which
is the way of getting them to the
temperature that you need to see the
transition I think if you want to
compete convey it to people who know
very little about science I think we can
explain the evaporative cooling maybe in
the language of this magnetic container
we have we have a box around our atoms
and this box is not made of material
it's made of magnetic fields if an atom
wants to leave the apparatus it is sent
back by magnetic fields so we should
have the notion that we have a box which
has magnetic walls but now by
controlling the magnetic fields we can
make the walls of the box soft and that
means energetic particles can penetrate
the walls and this is what Tom was
alluding to as a selection evaporation
mechanism the hottest particles can
penetrate the walls and can escape as a
result the atoms which are still in this
magnetic box have only a lower energy
than they initially had because the
highest energy particles could penetrate
the walls and as a result the gas has
lower energy and therefore a temperature
and what was invented by Tom school was
a way to control the strength of the
magnetic walls in a very carefully so by
making the walls softer more minute
level lower and lower energy particles
could escape and therefore the remaining
particles even knowing and this was the
key technique to enter micro and nano
containers so this opened up a new
temperature range for physicists but
experimental one couldn't do that with
the entire surface of the box yes we
could only do it with one end of the box
so no no becoming to technicalities how
do we soften the Von's could we
understand that I had magnetic coils and
you could soften them only at one point
simply because you were using magnetic
fields and superconducting coils to do
that and then there was a new idea which
allowed us to soften the vaults
everywhere so particles could just
escape in all directions so it was
though you found a way of punching hole
in the box
would we understand what was the advance
in the what how could how were you able
to have control over or is it or is that
more of a no no but but as far as the
the why wasn't that done before I guess
is it was it just the idea that was it
was not just it was a simple decided
shut I think that's it's just so logical
he was a postdoc with us and he came up
with this idea he came to Dan and I we
had reached an impasse in trying to work
with the hydrogen yeah and he came loose
and said I have an idea and he explained
it to us and dan and I just looked at
each other way of doing this we turned
around the entire direction and then
eventually we were able to demonstrate
the evaporation cool yeah I think it's
fair to say that ideas were out in the
idea of this
evacuation from the whole surface in it
it's you to Dave Pritchard and others
and I think it was voiced already in 89
so those ideas were out early on but the
problem is to come to the point that you
can implement that idea you were to
build a whole new machine so for me the
most critical part in the development to
what post condensation is that people
had to be convinced it would be
optimistically not about those ideas
that they were be willing that they were
willing to invest several years of their
killing yeah yeah all the resources in
equipment and collaborators and try it
out and this is something which I think
is important in physics there are ideas
out but ideas become real when people
vote with this we look at it the other
day each one of these things is a
serious outcome we turned into wires and
pumps and well we like as physicists to
reduce things to a two a one two three
these were the important concepts that
work but look yeah I mean there were
groups all around the world you
understand why it's very hard to do this
so it takes a team of graduate students
two years and half-a-million-dollar
to try out this idea just just and so
sometimes ideas are found that you can
trace them back and sometimes I'm amazed
how few groups pursue this goal I mean
for decades you equivalent the Amsterdam
cool almost well there are a few others
working on hydrogen - but yes hard
experience but you have to also have
incredible confidence in a way to to
know that you're on the right track you
must have had you must have had that
sense otherwise you you're not going to
go blow a half a million bucks under
under well did you make any did you did
you waste any time is it was there a
stage where you were heading in a
particular direction that I'm always
interested in me in the errors as well
that the miscalculation of the time to
figure out how to do it and then to
implement the idea which has survived
the failures this is fairly direct so
therefore once the techniques have been
developed other key other games
worldwide just tweak those ideas yeah I
meant them and that creates a big field
yeah also in that case the ideas or the
UT techniques were sufficiently
complicated
those methods and how is it becoming
more refined I'm assuming it is as as
time progresses you do you start editing
out certain areas that are not necessary
or or do you see it becomes symphysis I
had to use the word simpler but it does
in a way so I guess getting back to i
where where were you able to simplify
things that that you weren't aware of
before if we could understand if
somebody like myself could understand
something like that was there an area
that you were concentrating on that was
unnecessarily time-consuming for example
for the alkali atoms things went
amazingly smooth I mean it was clear in
the early 90s that in order to have a
major attempt at post condensation you
needed an efficient source of atoms you
needed ultra-high vacuum you need the
magnetic trap and you had to implement
the if' induced evaporation how is a
given and pretty much this is what we
engineer I think the only Maitre D' to a
beard is we didn't figure out
immediately what the best magnetic trap
was we experimented with different ways
of confining atoms magnetically and this
was actually the only point where to
reengineer
mm-hmm the other things were just to
learn how to master the technology if
you haven't produced ultra-high vacuum
in your lab you can easily waste many
months in in trying to pump down a
chamber and after weeks you figure out
it doesn't mean you have to do it again
so so there are many pitfalls but but
they're at a lower level this is just no
learning the nuts and bolts right yeah I
thought that there was quite a bit of
effort and a lot of maybe false leads in
the pre coin
the laser pre cooled
it moved very quickly because there were
a lot of very good people working on it
but early on we in this discussion so to
put aside the question of the
pre-cooling of the the alkalis but there
was quite a race there for a number of
years and the the densities and the
temperature densities were going up the
temperatures were dropping as various
atomic groups atomic physics groups
managed to use lasers and Mach traps in
one way or another to get atoms to the
point where you could begin to do the
evaporation of cooler it may have gone
quickly from Wolfgang's point of view
but it wasn't without a tremendous
amount of work and a number of very
innovative ideas I thought hmm I said we
don't do that so I can say that looking
from from aside yes I mean but the work
on obedience all you the alkalis most of
that happened in a period of 3 4 5 years
we started in the early 90s and
succeeded already 95 and they were not
there was no too much time to run in
into completely wrong directions but
this was something which caught me
completely by surprise because we all
knew from the approach in atomic
hydrogen which went on for in since the
late 70s that it was a decade-long
search and once you go into a new regime
of density and temperature you are in
unknown territory you don't know what is
in Roby and I should say even in the
most optimistic days when we try to do
that I felt we are just making one step
at a time I never got euphoric and I
always felt we have decades ahead of us
and that things happened in a few years
was a completely unattended it caught
everybody by surprise but you know in
the old maps they said here there'd be
Tigers well now you've got your tiger
trapped and there are two things I want
you to tell me
you to tell me what does it tell you and
what do you make it do what does it do
it's funny to think of a tiger which is
an energetic piece then we are talking
about the lowest energy system which is
given to us but so well okay it's a
special Tiger but that has two aspect
one is it is a new Bindu into the
quantum world it has new properties we
have taken all energy out of the system
which means we can see very weak effects
very subtle effects which cannot be
observed at all at higher temperature
hmm so we look at propagation of sound
we look how the whole thing shakes like
a piece of of jelly jelly and so we
study its properties but there's also a
second aspect and that is if we have
extracted all the energy we have we are
really now controlling the quantum state
is computed I can say position and
velocity to the ultimate degree to the
ultimate extent which is allowed by
quantum mechanics in other words the
whole cooling the production of the most
condensate gives us ultimate control
over atoms
that's what physics is about you want to
control matter and you want to control
it to learn more about matter but also
to use it for applications and we are
currently considering using such well
controlled matter for precision
measurements to build better at homee
clocks to look at fundamental forces of
nature so this is what we hope the
future will
us in exploring the properties of
quantum mechanics as a condensed matter
physicist I'm interested in the behavior
of matter in aggregate where the
dynamics of the system properties of the
system are determined not by the single
particle properties but the way they
interact and the both condensate is very
interesting in that regard because
because of its low density theorists can
do very good calculations calculations
which have a high probability being
accurate in a way that they can't do
with strongly interacting electron
systems super conductivity for example
high-temperature superconductivity is
still an unsolved problem or even closer
to this realm the properties of
superfluid helium for helium 4 is a
superfluid it has amazing properties we
understand it phenomenologically but
there is no really good microscopic
theory of superfluid helium super
fluidity and helium as opposed to super
fluidity in the gas because the system
is so dense that the atoms are basically
always touching each other is a strongly
correlated system and theories are much
harder to formulate and to carry out
there so the both gases give the
theorists now a wonderful opportunity of
looking at interacting systems in a way
where they they feel that their their
theories are both accurate and
computable it is an amazing world at
some point we looked at our gas the post
condensate in the magnetic container in
what we saw caught us completely by
surprise we saw that the system had
layers layers where the orientation of
the air tom was alternating this looks
like sort of an you know Liat cake I
mean it's something we are very familiar
with in the world of condensed matter
physics you can stack different
materials and they stay put but for gas
a system which is hundred thousand times
more dilute than the air around us you
would not expect that a gas can be
stacked in layers in other words what it
romantically tells us is that we are at
densities which are 10 to the 800
million times lower in density then the
ordinary condensed matter state but we
are observing phenomena or during
stacking miscibility immiscibility which
have been studied so far only in
condensed matter systems in liquids and
solids that's of course the paradox of
the name yes look this is a currency
that has yeah three variables just isn't
yes we have a million times lower
density so all those forces which create
ordering and other things are much much
weaker but we are at an energy scale
temperature scale which is under new
enzymes lowest-ranked
so that means we can observe really
generic condensed matter phenomenon at
extremely low density in the description
of matter at ultra low density is much
much simpler if the atoms are not
squeezed against each other
we don't have to understand the
complicated things which happen in the
proximity of an atom we only sort of
need need to know the simple physics
which happens at long range so therefore
we hope that we have now the tools to
acquaintance engineer condensed matter
systems and understand them in great
detail and learn something which we hope
is very general about nature I still
half of the atoms because this only
applies to atoms which are bosons the
other fraction of the atoms will be a
different kind of statistics Fermi
statistics and this phenomena just
doesn't do crap because a zero to low
temperatures
instead of allowing many of the atoms to
condense into each one of these states
there can be
only one atom in each one of the states
so instead of T equals zero all the
atoms in the bottom state at T equals
zero there's 1 and then 1 and then 1 and
then 1 until you go up to a total number
of states equal to the total number of
atoms each one has its own individual
state okay and bose-einstein
condensation doesn't occur in that
system but that system will be cracked
this is a detail question but I'm always
interested in what happens at interfaces
what is it is there something when the
when the this strata if I could use that
word at the very interface is there is
there something happening there do the
boundaries stake of printouts but
there's a picture which shows the
following if if you have the
magnetically when we take this
magnetically confines well is that
switch off the magnetic container that
the system flies apart we saw pictures
which just showed a regular array of
striation right and because we know what
has happened between here and there we
knew that the system in the magnetic
container consisted of alternating
layers of two different quantum states
so it was like a stack of alternating
layers of two different materials and
what was different the spin orientation
because it's been orientation but and
again maybe I'm thinking more about the
material world but what exactly happens
at that boundary if you're if you're
demarcated exactly you can imagine it it
is if you would carefully pour vinegar
yeah
and then add oil to it and you have
at vinegar again and you don't stir it
you're just very careful you would
create alternating layers I do
understand that but at the very
boundaries between the oil and the
vinegar something molecularly is
happening and I'm Jase is no different
between the gas what happens is what is
a sharp boundary between oil and vinegar
this is so foul so I would actually okay
that ii would taught the density
distribution I would draw it in this way
which would mean this is kind of our
claim to oil and vinegar and oil and
vinegar but because it is a gas the
overlap can this overlap is enforced by
twenty mechanics because an extremely
sharp boundary an abrupt change in the
quantum mechanical wave function costs
energy so therefore the system can lower
its energy by some penetrating okay so
this is again claimed to make any exit I
see is that an interesting place for you
this place here are you interested and
is there a thing I think is going on
here that are different from here and
here that is that could be interesting
hmm
it's a different if unless I'm
misunderstanding it it is a different
it's different from these two it's a
Third Circuit yes OSHA provisions will
be so it could it could it it it's just
a question about because I have a
chemistry orientation because that's
where very interesting things happen in
chemistry and I'm just wondering if it's
if there's a similar situation I think
that probably depends on the
interactions on the collisions because
the separation mechanism the the reason
that this doesn't go sharply to zero is
a quantum mechanical reason you can't
have the wavefunction drop rapidly to
zero unless you put in more energy so
even with no interactions you would have
this overlap
the interfacial phenomena that we're
familiar with in chemistry and physics
usually happened because of an
interaction between the the two
different systems and yes the
interactions are quite weak in these
Bose condensates not zero and certainly
Wolfgang has seen lots of effects of the
interactions but they they don't
dominate usually the system so I think
that's why it's a little hard for us to
answer your question probably there are
interesting things that are going on
that we may not be able to see them yet
but just to guide your imagination what
is the density and what makes an
interface between two gassy gases the
density of the material is hundred
thousand times less than the density of
air so it's almost nothing
yeah but we can see it we the methods of
atomic physics so if you would imagine I
take a microscope and look at to sort of
see those structures yes and so far I
should say we couldn't really resolve
the EF is region well because it is
comparable to the optical resolution
yeah so we have seen this interface only
indirectly when the whole system spreads
out we saw those magnified layers and
riku to some extent we use the atomic
motion to magnify because we couldn't
see it directly we are currently trying
in experiments we are setting up to see
those structures more directly but what
we have used so far is we have used the
atomic motion that things just burst a
listicle expand and we have used that as
a tool to magnify the structures and
then we could readily see them
so this is sort of for me the most
striking example that we are doing
contains metaphysics in a regime which
was unheard of yeah let me give you
another example in solid-state physics
one often has a magnetic system which
supports spin waves for example if you
have a Ferro magnet or an anti
ferromagnetic where you have a solid the
magnetic moments on the individual
atomic sites and they may if you tweak
the system you can get a spin wave so
that the spins will oscillate in
Direction up down up down as you move
along the sample the reason that that
wave exists the way the reason you have
a restoring force is that the wave
function of the electrons on one atom
overlap the wave function of the items
on another so it's natural to say sure I
spin wave of course if I flip the spin
on one atom it's going to affect the
neighboring atom no problem it's been
waves exist and we've seen them for a
long time in the process of trying to
get atomic hydrogen colder and colder we
reached a place where we had some very
cold hydrogen but not cold enough to
both condense and a group at cornell
university did an experiment where they
saw spin waves in this gas of atomic
hydrogen and the interesting thing about
those spin waves was that the atoms were
about at least a thousand times their
mean diameter apart it was an extremely
low density gas but there was a spin
wave a beautifully well-defined very
sharply detected in a magnetic resonance
experiment you could see this thing
extremely clearly beautifully
well-defined
but the atoms were a thousand times
apart compared to their own distance and
this collective wave in the dispence
existed and it's because of quantum
mechanics and just again a very
beautiful example of a cooperative
phenomena in an extremely low dense
system low densities
I wish we lose it you can probably apply
to this the phrase which was used in a
different context of mechanics is little
bit spooky things happen at a distance
where normally things would not happen
yeah and the spin waves in an ultra
dilute gas of hydrogen are a nice
example that when two mechanics has
different scales as we would usually
associate that that's hard to grasp as
well scale it's always difficult
well localization is a fragile thing we
think of localization as being
everything must be localized
yeah yeah okay what time is it someone I
think there's a lot of material here I
think that there's some good stuff
wonderful conversation it's interesting
it's it had it in a completely different
your affection I wonder if we all had an
idea of how this conversation was going
to I have imagined you drawing for me
all these wonderful things and yes and
you did yeah druing in other ways
any final question so we think the new
clarity or there was the business of the
daughters of the eye
oh it's just a way of extrapolating yeah
but no it's an explanation because it
connects to zoo experience trying to
describe the weight of the BBC and I
said well it's like this a period of ink
on the paper is pretty small
you believe that if you were very good
Rex I was you don't have and could
somehow draw a thousand lines on it this
way and a thousand lines across it this
way I took one of those pieces that
would be a hundred times the weight of a
bull's Clemens it is about one pinned
okay can't even conceive but it's things
like that that are so easy an argument
to follow you are not frightened of it
you're not required to go through so
many steps that you can follow us and
you're left with an image which you then
used as you listen to the next step
that's the first thing but you call it a
condensate well because it is yeah
that's what when I first wrote you I
said kid can you talk to me that you
know the word condensate is that the
right word no it's not the right word
but this is what we associate everydays
life but it is it is a weird chocolate
in a weird waiver and the weirdness is
the quaint weirdness but I mean these
are real data what it depicts is this
it's it's false color coding it means
low density red means high density but
what you see is you see this
created gaseous cloud and it's elongated
because our magnetic container is
cylindrically shaped and now we cool
down a gas which is cool down shrinks
and you sort of see how the wings of
this distribution shrink it gets colder
and the gas is kind of more concentrated
at the bottom of the father
that's what cooling is about but then
you see it a very well-defined point all
of a sudden yeah color coded in red
there is a tablet there's a high density
phase and this droplet is the most
condensate so somehow this looks very
similar if you look at the vapor you
cool it down and you reach the onset of
condensation and then two updates appear
in the vapor but the top late' is
acquaintance mechanical state the Bose
condensate and the vapor is not
saturated because it has reached a
saturated vapor in the ordinary sense
but in the sense which Tom mentioned
it's a twenty of statistical sense it is
Quentin saturated hmm and it would be
difficult to explain what it means but
just the analogy with a waiver which
cools down into off let's appear this is
what we visually see when we look into
our magnetic container I found this
image very mysterious and why did you
just told me that by the way the
suddenness you talked to you you said
use that word that point that point in
time when that happens gives you
information if it happened another time
it would mean something else is it would
that be is that fair to say the fact
that it's happening happening at that
time is giving when you hit a critical
density in the bottom of the trap is it
is would it be a whether it be the same
with any alkali is it is the the same
density dependent is the density
dependent that is a pretty good scheme a
scarce and the properties of theater
that you own is a mess that's right
but but the suddenness is sort of really
striking I mean imagine you see a system
which slowly gets colder colder colder
and all of a sudden something happens I
mean if you would cool down the air in
this room it gets colder sure you start
freezing it gets even colder even colder
but all of a sudden yeah
liquid air appears and this is what Tom
described as the phase transition yeah a
sudden change in the physical properties
and this suddenness depends only on
temperature and density that's all yes
whenever we put in a system down to the
same temperature and the same density
exactly the same thing Emma's it defines
a phase transition line density versus
temperature
and if one cools down at different
densities you hit this at different
temperatures yeah and by mapping out the
way the density varies as a function of
temperature you measure the phase
transition line just as you would in any
other phase transition and that was one
of these signatures that this was in
fact those Einstein condensation are not
something else yeah nice wonderful thank
you